hi guys dr. Burke here I want to answer
the question how long does it take to
get into ketosis that's fat-burning
right it's good question
a lot of times people expect it you know
to happen in like 2 minutes it's not
going to happen that fast right I want
you to really understand you've been
living under your whole life okay
and now we're going to switch over to a
completely different fuel source your
cells have to build new machines for fat
they have to build new enzymes to break
down a completely different source of
fuel that takes some time now if you're
really healthy it can happen in maybe a
week but an average it's going to be
about a month to six weeks of completely
switching up so your body is going to
change you're going to feel different
but the question is how do you know when
it's starting to work okay well first of
all when you are satisfied after you eat
you can go long periods of time without
eating and not being hungry you don't
have sugar cravings anymore your brain
is more cognitive if you have more focus
less you know brain fog it's basically
better blood sugars okay you're
remembering sharper lets you know
urinating through the night so those are
all factors to look for but in the
process you might you might have any one
of these symptoms right here and those
are good things because your body is
just making the adjustment and you've
got to do it you can't make the key to
adaptation like halfway like you can't
do like a diet with some sugar every day
and expect it to adapt you got to bring
that sugar down to zero yeah to really
make this work so it's like
all-or-nothing because in the presence
of sugar your body will always burn that
it will not go after the fat so we're
training your body to adapt evaporating
but once you get there you will never go
back because you're going to feel so
much better and of course you're going
to lose a lot of weight but here's some
things that you can do fatigue
if you have fatigue all that means is
you're deficient in a certain B vitamin
b5 pantothenic acid it's really easy
just go ahead and start taking some and
your energy will come up why because b5
is kind of like a helper for these fat
burning enzymes to work if you don't
have enough b5 because you're stressed
well you're going to get tired so you
have to feed it what it needs start
getting cramps in the muscle that means
you deficient in potassium well if
you're following my eating plan you're
on about seven to ten cups of vegetable
per day so you're not going to have a
problem with that but you cannot do a
ketose diet correctly if you're not
consuming vegetables it's not an
insufficient quantity because potassium
is needed not just to flesh out all this
fat from the liver but to help you with
the nervous system and the muscles
that's an electrolyte because with
ketosis you're going to dump a lot of
fluid weight so you need to retain some
of these electrolytes right and also
salt is that's another one if you get
muscle like weakness you need some salt
ok bloating bile salts purify bile salts
that's my gallbladder formula here's a
mistake that people make they start the
ketosis but they go too heavy on the
fats too fast and it blows out the
gallbladder and the cause right shoulder
pain you just can't handle the fat so
you want to start small with the fats
and gradually increase it so you don't
feel too heavy in your digestive system
sleep issues that's a calcium magnesium
issue if you if you're going through
this so if you're not sleeping you're
sleeping is worse add some calcium
magnesium boom you go to sleep
okay so I just wanted to kind of explain
that give it some time be patient it's
going to work it always does
but just increase your expectation of
the time it's going to take and don't
think it's going to take a day or two
and then it also doesn't work so you
quit all right
I'll see in the next video hey guys
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it
please click the share button below and
I will see you in the next video